we are out here at
about 5 a.m
to photo scan a mountain
we got the drone
we got jan
we got the climbing gear
so let's rope up get to the top of this
mountain and scan it
so we can process our data in reality
capture and create a photo real scene in
unreal engine 5.
no no on the screen on the screen
photogrammetry is the process of
stitching hundreds sometimes thousands
of images together to create a high
resolution 3d model aerial
photogrammetry works exactly the same
except we use a drone to capture our
images instead of our phone or dslr and
since i'm a 3d and vfx artist i 3d scan
things to make exact duplicates of real
world objects when traditional 3d
modeling and texturing is either too
much work or near impossible 3d scanning
takes a while to get used to it takes a
little bit of practice to make sure
you're doing it right so in this video i
hope to walk you guys through all the
different steps tips and techniques
that'll help you shoot better process
your data better and in the end get
better 3d scans now this video is
building off information in a previous
3d scanning video where i covered the
entire workflow so be sure to check that
one out as well
couple things that i'm trying to do
when i am scanning with a drone first
off
try and treat it like a normal scan you
can get easily overwhelmed with the size
of the object you're scanning say like
these mountains here so to keep it easy
i will try and capture the entire object
in frame for my first pass
then you can go in for your detail shots
now generally you want to capture
whatever you're trying to capture from
every angle possible just go from left
to right i'm moving
as a just like a planar planar movement
from left to right along the mountain
boom up a little bit
and go back up a little bit and come
back you're quite literally scanning the
mountain
and
then i'm going to
tilt down
and do that same thing to get all of the
higher angle shots and i'll do the same
from below as well lower my altitude
tilt up and do the same scans
that way you're capturing
every possible angle of the mountain
another thing to look out for are your
camera settings of course reality
capture is going to do a much better job
of stitching your images together when
they are shot with the same exposure the
same shutter speed you want a high
shutter speed because you don't want
blurry images autofocus will be your
friend definitely keep that on manual
iso you want all that stuff locked white
balance you want that locked as well all
of your photos need to be consistent
when you're shooting doesn't matter if
you're using a drone or if you're
photo scanning with your phone
so in a perfect situation you're going
to want overcast lighting that way you
can change the light in 3d later to
whatever light conditions you want
living out here in la we don't always
have that luxury so we try to get here
as early as possible to get the earliest
scans when the sun quite didn't touch
the mountains and we'll be staying a
little bit later too for the same reason
we are racing the sun
i'm gonna try and get echo clips while
still completely covered in shade
because that's ideal for scans you want
to get it de-lit essentially
and we were promised yeah and we were
promised some cloud layer here but that
is not
the case
if you have a histogram take a look at
it and imagine a even centered hill
right in that histogram if it's too
crunched to the left or the right that's
no good keep that hill nice and centered
capturing the full range of your image
let's do it
let's do it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my god
[Music]
terrifying
why i did it from the side of the
mountain
[Music]
it is good to be home
especially after all that because that
was
absolutely
terrifying
so let's get into these 3d scans
there's a number of different programs
we can use to stitch our images together
but my go-to program has always been
reality capture by capturing reality the
sponsor of today's video
reality capture is a state-of-the-art
photogrammetry program used to create 3d
meshes orthographic projections
geo-referenced maps and more
automatically from images or laser scans
and besides basic features like creating
a point cloud meshing that point cloud
texturing that mesh and exporting an fbx
reality capture is packed full of
various tools to help you refine
optimize and export your 3d scans which
we'll get into when processing our
mountains
it's cool too because there's no limit
to how much data you can throw at the
program it can process anything from
tiny toys to entire cities reality
capture is free to download and they
actually have a number of free data sets
on their site you can get experimenting
with and export for free right away but
usually reality capture works off their
pay-per-input method where you pay a
small fee that's based on your total
megapixel count across all your images
to export your 3d scan
and through the end of september you can
get 50 off 3 500 ppi points by using the
code punisher 50. so click that link in
the description and check it out
i've also included my mountain images
for download below so you can follow
along in the program so let's get
started
so the first thing we need to do when
processing our 3d scans is to de-light
our images and it's going to be easiest
to do so on the raw images so if you can
shoot raw definitely do so i'm using
lightroom because i find it's the
easiest way to batch edit photos
but you can use whatever program you
want at the top left i'll click add
photos
we will browse to
our scan for our raw photos
and we'll go ahead and open these up by
clicking add 140 photos and i'll
navigate to a photo that has both
sunlight and shadows in it and by going
to this top right option here we're
going to open up all of our image
settings the first thing i'll do is
adjust the color profile because this is
applying like a little bit of color
correction to our image and we want to
work with the flattest image possible so
under profile let's go ahead and change
to let's browse all profiles
we'll go to adobe raw and we'll select
adobe neutral and that's going to ensure
that it takes the pre-built color
correction off of our image now from
here
we can boost our shadows
we can drop our highlights we can also
drop our white value
and if you don't have a histogram if
you're not seeing that you can hit the
little ellipsis here
and click show histogram
you can see here it's a little
underexposed i want to bring this right
up into the middle so i'll bring my
exposure up so that that
little hill there that peak is right in
the middle of our image
and finally i'll adjust the white
balance it's a little
off so i'll set it to custom
and we'll set the temperature to 5600
that feels
about good to me we don't need to do any
image distortion correction reality
capture takes all that into account and
does its own work behind the scenes so
in order to copy these settings across
the board to all of your other images
let's go back
to
all of our images and we'll hit ctrl c
for copy ctrl a to select all and
control v
to paste
and it's as easy as that all we have to
do is right click and export
140 photos image type jpeg is fine full
size and 100 quality is the way to go
and i'll just export these into a
processed folder
so now we can process our images in
reality capture and when you first open
the program you'll be introduced to all
these different options to start
learning and diving into but let's
import our images the first thing i'm
going to do is at the top left change
our viewport layout these are all
different viewport layouts but the third
one is my favorite as it's the cleanest
and is all we really need for what we're
about to do now you can drag your images
in your processed images in to the
viewport you can drag them in over here
to the left let's try that and you can
see immediately 140 images were loaded
you might be in the 2ds view where you
get to see like a visualization of your
images but i prefer the 1ds i'm going to
hold this down let go on 1ds
and you can drop down this little bit
here you can get a bunch of different
information on your image you can also
set control points if you're trying to
do that later but we're getting ahead of
ourselves
the first thing we want to do is align
these images and i want to show you all
how easy it is to do so how fast and how
automatic this process is
we can do it a number of different ways
but by going to the workflow tab
if we navigate over to align images we
can click that or we can just go to the
alignment tab where we have all of our
alignment settings and i'm just going to
click align images
wait a couple seconds
and look at this
we have
all of our different cameras here
lined up
you can see all these little dots in the
sky are
different camera positions you can see i
just
you know kind of
went along the formation of the cliff
i'm holding right click here to orbit
around this model
left click and hold will pan
and move myself around the scene and you
can scroll wheel to
zoom in as well
so as you can see if we kind of back up
far enough
we got a nice
point cloud view
of our 3d scan and this looks
super cool i can't wait to mesh this but
before we mesh it let's go ahead and
just line it up a little bit to the grid
so if we go to the 3d tools tab and we
hit set ground plane we'll get this
little gizmo and we can actually
just orient this
so it's lined up with our grid
we can uncheck that option and if we hit
set reconstruction region it'll reorient
this box now this box is what will be
meshed so if we
scrunch this in
right just this little section will be
mesh we don't want to mesh the entire
thing we want to mesh maybe just a
section but for our case i'm gonna go
ahead and
do
most of this thing
and let's go ahead and bring it bring it
up here
let's bring this down just a touch
and you can also hit the numpad
buttons to orient between left right top
bottom views and if you hit zero it'll
go back to
your main view
if for whatever reason
you guys did your alignment and you look
here on the left if we drop this down we
can see camera poses we have 140
registered images that means it used all
140 images to build
this point cloud
now if you have component 0 component 1
and component 2
then you guys are going to have to use
control points to bridge those
components together
and i'm not going to go over control
points in this video but the last video
i did on the full 3d scanning process i
go over control points in detail so be
sure to check it out if you guys are
having issues trying to combine
different components and set control
points
well let's go ahead and mesh this point
cloud we can go to the mesh model tab
here up at the top and we can mesh in
high detail but it's usually not
necessary normal detail should be fine
so let's click that and see what we get
be warned this can take
a while
bam and we have
a nice 3d mesh right here this is
looking really great we're going to
clean this up next but let me just walk
you through kind of what we're looking
at so if you are seeing kind of a point
cloud version
of your mesh that's because there's one
of two reasons either one
your view if you go to the view tab
it's set to vertices and it's just going
to look like a point cloud version
if you have sweet grayed out that's
because your model is above 40 million
tries and 40 million tries is the cap
for
reality captures real time render here
in the viewport
if it's above 40 million tries you'll
need to go to the view tab and use the
clipping box
to
only view a portion
of
your mesh
but in our case since it's under 40
million tries we can
view it in its full glory
we can turn off the clipping box
and let's clean this thing up if we go
to the 3d tools tab
we have a few different options here to
select and deselect
different parts of our mesh so what i'm
going to do
is actually grab the lasso tool
and kind of just draw
the area that i want to keep
and i'll navigate just around this bit
here
we'll come up the side of the mountain
and we're basically just going to chop
off
all this stuff that we don't want to
view i'll grab this rock
and this whole
bit here is nice so that's that's not
too bad there now we can take this and
invert the selection by clicking the
invert button there and we can filter
out our selection by clicking filter
selection
and that's going to make a new model
here under component zero now you see
all these nasty blue triangles back here
we can get rid of those
if we go to the advanced section here we
can uncheck the lasso tool and we can
select marginal triangles which those
are
or another way we can do it is select
the largest connected component which is
our mountain
and once again we can just invert that
selection and filter it out wonderful
now we just have our mountain mesh next
what we'll do is texture this thing and
i want to
talk about
a couple different ways to texture this
specifically the best way to texture
this so i'll go to the mesh model tab
and instead of just hitting texture
let's go to the settings tab and bring
this up
and i'll go ahead and
open up my unwrap parameters
so
i want to set my texture resolution to
the highest possible resolution
so that will be 16k
perfect the large triangle removal
threshold by default is set to 10 but
i'm gonna have this set to 100
and we want our style
by default its maximal texture count but
i'm going to set that to fixed texel
size and i'll make sure texel size is
set to
optimal it's going to make as many 16k
textures as it needs to in order to
texture this entire mountain face and
with these settings we'll just hit
texture
bam
look at that
look at this here's me i'm chilling up
here hanging from the top of this
mountain
heck yeah and we got ourselves a
textured
mountain amazing this right here is
gonna be our high quality photo scan
this is what we can make leds from this
is what we can simplify because we don't
want to bring in a 24 million triangle
mountain into unreal engine or into
blender or in the c4d we're going to
want to simplify this we're going to
unwrap it and then we're going to
reproject this high-res texture onto
our simplified mesh
so let's get started by closing out our
texture settings here
and under the 3d tools tab i will
navigate to the simplify tool
and we can set our target triangle count
i'm actually going to go with
5 million and we want to disable our
color reprojection and our normal
reprojection because i want to show you
all a method that gives us full control
over our texture reprojection in just a
second so let's go ahead and simplify
this model simplification is complete we
have our model 3 at 24 million tries and
our new simplified model 4 at 5 million
tries
perfect
so let's go ahead and close this out if
we drop down model 4 we can see we don't
have any textures like we talked about
what we're seeing here are actually just
vertex colors for reference here
so
the first thing we need to do before
reprojecting our texture is unwrap this
thing so if we go to the mesh model tab
we can click on the unwrap settings
now if we drop down our unwrap
parameters we can take a look at our
settings
we want 16k textures
for sure we want that large triangle
removal threshold set to 100 as well
and we want a maximal texture count
of one
and we'll unwrap this
awesome now this thing looks like uh
a real pain to look at actually
careful watch your eyes
so it is unwrapped it's prepped for the
texture reprojection
so let's go ahead and close our unwrap
tool
and let's go back to our 3d tools and
we'll click on texture reprojection
we're just going to ensure first off
that our source model which should be
model number three that is our
hi-res 24 million tri model that will be
our source
for our result that's this model right
here model number four our five million
tri model so make sure those are set
correctly we want color reprojection
enabled of course we want that color
texture and we also want to enable
normal reprojection we want a normal map
as well because a lot of the details we
lost
by simplifying this 5 million polygon
model we're going to bring back with
that normal map from our high res
model number three and with that we can
reproject
amazing now we have our simplified five
million
polygon model
with two textures on it we have one 16k
normal and one 16k color and now this is
optimized simplified and ready for
export and the easiest way to do that is
to go up to the top left here
and click export and i want to export an
fbx you can search for it here that's
one of my recently used formats i'll
just click on that save it all right so
for our settings let's go over these
uh we don't want to save the mesh by
parts so setting that to no is great fbx
that's what we chose that's perfect
um let us see texture settings right so
we definitely want to export textures
that's for sure
and we want a texture size of 16k you
can choose ak you can choose 32k if you
want 16k is plenty for us right now 8k
i'm sure would be great as well
now we can unravel the color and normal
layers as well we want to make sure
we're both exporting the color and the
normal texture
that's exactly what we want and as a
little bonus here
let's drop down the export
transformation settings if we set the
transformation preset to maya arnold and
unreal it's actually going to
scale your scene
by 100 that way we don't have to
scale our model every single time we
bring it into unreal and with that
we can hit ok so let's see what our scan
looks like in unreal five i'm also going
to show you how to build a master
material where you can control tint
saturation brightness and normal
intensity so i'm just gonna drag
our fbx here into the content browser
and we'll be prompted with this little
fbx import option here now usually i
always want to build a nanite mesh so
i'll check the nanite mesh box here and
for materials i'm going to drag in our
materials manually so i just set this to
do not create an unchecked import
materials
and we don't have to worry about import
scale because we already set that up in
reality capture when we exported and
we'll go ahead and import all fun facts
so if your little thumbnail display
looks strange and doesn't truly display
what you're bringing in if you go to
settings and check thumbnail edit mode
you can actually just click and drag to
orbit your thumbnail around
and when you're done you can just hit
done editing and i'll drag in
our 16k
diffuse map and i actually rendered out
an 8k normal map because a 16k normal
map crashes my version of unreal
maybe it works for you but 8k it is for
now so let's drag this out
oh my goodness right click and i'm using
wasd
to move around this thing is ginormous
which is exactly what we want this looks
awesome
but it needs a material so let's go
ahead and right click make a material
we'll just call this mountain master
material
and we'll go ahead and double click
and get this thing set up first i'll
just drag our diffuse and normal
textures into our scene
and we'll pipe the rgb in the base color
and the rgb for the normal into normal
now that is the most basic way to set
this up but i want to show you guys how
to get more control over all of this so
let's start with the normal map and make
a normal intensity setup the first thing
i'll do is hold 3 and make a constant 3
vector i'll navigate to the left side
here and change the blue channel to one
so now we have a solid blue
and we have a normal map which is mostly
blue it uses all the color channels but
blue it works off of kind of the blue
channel as its main now if we can slide
between
blue solid blue and blue with detail
then we can effectively set up a normal
intensity and the best way to slide
between two things is with a lerp node
and i'll hold l left click to set that
up
and it's as easy as taking the rgb from
our normal map into b
this constant 3 vector our blue solid
and a and i'll hold s to make a
parameter i'll call this normal
intensity
and that will be plugged right into the
alpha as our control right
and we'll plug that into the normal map
so by default this normal intensity is
set to zero and you can see here on the
left and the preview it's turned off but
if i take it up to say like 20
we're maxing it out right we can of
course go up to 100 it can get crazy but
one is default that is perfect and that
is all we need to set up our normal
intensity setup i'll hit c
call this normal
and that is it for that
now for the color node for the color
texture
i want to set up three things i want to
do a tint
to be able to tint it i want to be able
to have a saturation control and i want
to be able to have a brightness
control and we're going to do all of
that
right up in here so let's um
let's turn this off let's get this out
of here
and we'll start with the tint so again
we're going to need that constant 3
vector we need a
a solid right so i'm going to hold 3 and
left click that's going to make our
color solid we can make it any color we
want but by default we're going to set
it to white that will essentially be
turning it off it's like the same idea
and i'm going to combine this with the
texture with a multiply node i'll hold m
and left click
boom we got ourselves a multiply
and i'll pipe that into b i'll pipe this
into a
and that's exactly what we need we can
pipe this into base color
now if we change the color of this
we can effectively tint it whatever
color we want
but by default
let's stick with white which turns it
off
next let's do saturation
so i'm gonna use a lerp node
hold l left click alright and we want to
kind of slide between
a saturated version
of our texture and that's what we set up
here so i'll take this multiply into b
and i want to slide between this and a
desaturated version and i'm just going
to pull one of these color channels
because they are black and white by
default
right into a and we can hold s
make a parameter
i'll call this saturation
plug that into the alpha
and at default if i plug this into base
color now
right 0 gives us a black and white image
20 gives us something really saturated
and 1 is default that's exactly what we
want and finally let's set up a
brightness control very very simple a
multiply node
hold m and left click
we'll pipe this in
all the way through
and hold s
for a parameter
i'll call this brightness
plug right into b
and by default it's set to zero it's
gonna just be
total darkness
one gets us a normal looking effect and
20
totally maxes it out
so that's about it the only thing we
need to do is right click this color
node here and convert it to a parameter
we'll call it tint
and we can select all this hit c
title it albedo and we're almost done i
just want to have control over the
specular and roughness channels of our
material as well so i'll right click
specular
bring that out right click roughness
that's good to go
and i'll stick to the qixel mega scans
defaults specular they usually do 0.5
roughness of one
and that should do it i'll save close
out and we can right click our master
material and create a material instance
which we can apply to
our 3d mesh right here
boom wonderful two things i want to do
setup wise i'll double click
the actual
scan itself
and i'm going to apply
this material instance to it
so by default it just comes out with
this material and i want to adjust a
couple of these parameters in the
material instance
so let's give it a slightly warmer tint
and i want to give it a bit more normal
intensity so i'll set that to about
three and that feels pretty good
to me
bam we got ourselves
a solid photo scan here
this is pretty good for like mid-ground
background kind of scans the closer you
get with your drone to the actual
mountain the higher res your 3d mesh
will be
thank you so much for watching i hope
you all learned something new in this
video and are getting inspired to do
your own 3d scans it's a blast and it's
such a cool way to start collecting your
own asset library of unique custom
assets
if you want to get your hands on these
photo scans i do have them uploaded to
my patreon otherwise you can download
the processed images i have of one of
the scans and run it in reality capture
yourself
good luck and happy scanning see you
guys next week
[Music]
you